لو سمعت ان البنك الذي تودع فيه اموالك
سينهار او سيعلن افلاسه ماذا ستفعل
بالتاكيد ستذهب باسرع وقت لاقرب فرع لسحب
مدخراتك وهذا ما حدث مع عملاء بنك سيليكون
فالي قبل ايام فما حصل معهم يطلق عليه
الذعر المصرفي فما اسبابه وكيف يمكن منعه
او الحد منه
لعلمكم اثار المصرفي قد لا يحدث فقط عندما
يواجه بنك ما خطر الانهيار بل قد يصيب حتى
البنوك التي تتمتع بوضع جيد ففي حال
ارتفعت عمليات سحب العملاء ستقود في
النهايه الى الافلاس هذا لان معظم البنوك
لا تحتفظ بكميه كبيره من الاموال في
فروعها لكن عندما توجد هناك ضروره لزياده
الاموال او السيوله لتلبيه طلبات السحب
فقد تبيع اصولها وعاده ما تبيعها باسعار
اقل بكثير مما كانت ستحققها وهذا هو
السيناريو نفسه الذي حصل مع بنك سيليكون
غالي في امريكا فالخسائر الناتجه عن بيع
الاصول باسعار اقل قد تتسبب في انهيار
البنك والشركات التي يدعمها
[موسيقى]
حالات الزعر المصرفي نوعان عاديه وصامته
فالاولى كما تكون في شكل طابور طويل من
العملاء للوصول الى الصراف الالي او فرع
البنك لاغلاق حساباتهم اما الحاله الصامته
فتحدث عندما يسحب المودعون اموالهم عبر
الانترنت بمبالغ كبيره بدون الذهاب الى
مقر البنك
لكن يبقى السؤال الابرز هنا كيف يمكن الحد
من مخاطر حالات الذعر المصرفي مستقبلا
اولا قد يحتاج البنك لاغلاق ابوابه لفتره
اذا واجه خطر الذعر المصرفي وهذه الخطوه
تمنع الناس من الاصطفاف امام البنك لسحب
اموالهم ثانيا يمكن ان يقترض البنك من
مؤسسات اخرى في حال لم تكن لديه احتياطات
نقديه كافيه لتلبيه طلبات عملائه ثالثا
يمكن للعملاء ان يؤمنوا على ودائعهم
فببساطه عندما يعلمون ان ودائعهم مؤمن
عليها يتراجع خوفهم
شاركونا ارائكم مع وجود مخاوف من انهيار
بلوك اخرى في هذه الفتره كيف يمكن للاشخاص
الاحتفاظ باموالهم